and now we're back from Camden back to
Hollywood ladies and gentlemen and
ladies hold on to your seats to present
the award for the best actress an
Academy Award winning actor Ronald
Colman those nominated for the Best
Performance by an actress are Shirley
booth come back little Sheba Hal Wallis
paramount Joan Crawford sudden fear
Kaufman Akio Betty Davis the star treat
lobe 20th Century Fox the Julie Harris
the member of the wedding Kraemer
Columbia and Susan Hayward with a song
in my heart 20th Century Fox and the
winner in New York is Shirley booth
that we about 20 minutes ago we had a
wire from the coast say you've been very
good boys we've been upped in our time
from a minute and 15 seconds to about 25
minutes for you to make a speech ah
popular win
I'm a very happy and a very lucky girl
My Luck has many many names I won't
attempt to list them all all you have to
do is look at the screen credits and
you'll know what I mean
I never could have done it alone you
know I couldn't it's been a long long
climb I guess this is the peak but the
view has been wonderful all along the
way I want to thank my old friends for
their faith my new friends for their
hope and everyone for their charity
thank
probably get a nasty note from Doug jr.
hey doll